in this episode I will show you how to
display and hide a loading spinner when
retrieving a synchronous fire-based data
from an angular application loading
indicators are an important user
interface feature because they show the
end user when more data is incoming step
1 create the spinner component we're
going to create a spinner component that
can be reused throughout the application
to make it look cool I'm going to use
the spin kit CSS library which can just
be copied directly into the components
CSS and HTML files at this point you
don't need to change anything in the
components typescript step to retrieve
asynchronous data we need to load some
data from firebase in order to make use
of the spinner in this example I'm
loading a firebase list observable via
the angular fire to package the actual
data is just an array of items from a
to-do list this code is originally
created for the real-time database video
so check out it if you want to learn
more about asynchronous data streams
from firebase step 3 the show and hide
the spinner we want to show the spinner
in the items list component when the
data is being retrieved
first we define a variable called show
spinner in the component and set it to
true by default during the ng on a net
life cycle so the data is requested from
the service as the firebase lists
observable we can determine if the data
has been loaded by subscribing to it the
function inside the subscribed call will
be executed after the observable emits
some data so we can simply set the show
spinner variable to false once this
happens in the template we can use the
ng-if directive with the show spinner
variable to control the visibility of
the actual spinner component itself
going back to the app we can see the
spinner is visible for a split second
before the data is loaded the longer it
takes for your data to load the more
useful the spinner is going to be for
your end-users that's it for loading
spinners see you next time
[Music]